how the gun rest my name welcome back to
some more happy with us
shall we play some bachmeier battle
manly right I think yeah it is shut up
son it's a regular [ __ ] ferris wheel
you wanted to go to the amusement park
this is what you get alright coming son
alright cannonball no alright God sad
okay I can't even scream holy [ __ ] do it
for me
ah you missed you're [ __ ] crazy
I'm sorry dude ah I'm so disappointed
I'm so sorry I'll try I was really close
to first place and uncared close doesn't
do anything you do it this time and you
do it properly son okay twenty said the
best you can do you're a big [ __ ] I'm
sorry dude go go son don't go backwards
just dip it all right dad go Sean
make me proud 11 that the best you can
do holy [ __ ] he's sex yet before is
let's try this with Santa clash Rania
Japan strong all right faster faster you
think I'm gonna punch instead yup oh no
you see that was that's what [ __ ]
happens when you down to run properly
run faster your daddy oh ho ho ho I lost
my hat you will pay for it later
oh no oh oh what the hell oh no it's
okay that's alright still going strong I
don't need your daddy peasants to run
forward I am [ __ ] Santa Claus
go I know I know how am I still moving
forward how
I'm still doing it summer I am sad you
clash I don't care I don't need anything
all right what do we got here
holy [ __ ] this is freaking epic Oh
[ __ ] snow snow never challenge Yeti
go to the first hole you see what I'm
supposed to go backward oh okay
I'm stuck all right backwards and we did
it lovely
that was too easy I'm such about big all
right son JB crap sucker terrible little
standard average good what the [ __ ] and
if you finished have to do this guy look
like I care now forever we're together
forever all right son you go first
dad I don't care shut up I'm better off
without you look I take it to the [ __ ]
Wow oh [ __ ] yes because I didn't have
you with me go away no all right
actually let's I can't do that voice
anymore like I don't know awesome
he just injected himself the killer Stan
JB I hate you all right let's go
that's that [ __ ] oh no son this is all
your fault I'm sorry I got careless what
did your dead I'm so sorry didn't start
it's not good enough you're just
spanking tonight all right
one more try we can do this son don't
[ __ ] up without a shot
look what your dad like with your dead
son I don't care
sorry-sorry has never helped anyone in
life
Bruntlett yo Shawn you can dude you are
so close but you failed me I hate you
I'm sorry I don't I don't care what you
I go back and finish it go back and
finish it Italia what a dish that we
bitumen ethic offensive [ __ ] thing I
don't know if the baby it fit counts
like it's the baby that all right now go
parties my son don't know okay I want to
try one more finishing for the baby
because I know I can do it from flap
yeah dad got fired you can do it honest
[ __ ] he made it does it look like I care
baby I don't know I can't really see
I don't care look at my bicycle that's
the biggest oh I can still do this I
guess I'm coming for your son I'm coming
I don't care about your victory you're
not gonna outmatch me
does it look like I need a hospital
huh you need a hospital unit a fracking
shut up pal you know what that is now I
never heard of it well you should buy
one kiss alright I'm finishing this that
all now this is all your fault I [ __ ]
hate ya all right I think that's enough
that ending was epic okay one more I
don't I got the happy wheels syndrome I
just can't [ __ ] stop it's too fun
all right let's do the capital all right
I love you so much my dear wife I love
youto let's go out and play but to have
a shut up
back off give me my space I need my
space say this is what happens when you
don't give me my space what am I
supposed to do here I think I need
another character like the sanguinary or
something
all right back Wow Holly [ __ ] no nothing
down no no stop betting place Oh No
all right I can still do this come in
come in come in come here come here
let's go
No that's better No Oh God dabit ah [ __ ]
me again this is like pretty badass
stuff let me get comfortable
alright I'm comfortable let's go don't
stop spinning oh oh no my legs it's okay
it's okay
we don't need legs here we don't need
legs here actually it's not moving
anymore
I think I need my arms at least and I
don't go no go you got this son yeah oh
no no no no it's okay you have one arm
you have one arm you don't need to you
don't need a face either okay maybe you
need a face come on buddy we're gonna
finish this get comfortable get
comfortable there we go
that's not bad that's pretty epic all
right let's go
Wow look at this position awesome whoa
you can do this don't oh thank you
bounce buddy no no I'll tell you doing
don't do anything stupid
don't try to merge yourself with it he's
trying to become one with the bike go
back lip run step double sunset oh damn
oh gee nice job bro thank you all right
you don't need legs don't worry you got
this all right one more just one more
glass know we are they'll play that
extreme Segway guy what is this Zed all
right
climbing like a bow screaming like about
get a squeeze through this one
is okay I've done better I know this one
in comer Sutra you just got it you just
got it ah yeah all right go through here
don't kill yourself
dad beer up Brad they're up all right
sweet sweet all right chip guy mom oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no ow ow it hurts
it hurts it hurts all right I'm just
rest here on this one ah you like that
you like that ball yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah oh no oh no oh no oh no all right
ah okay I should stop I'm sorry all
right
like impervious if you don't subscribe
to come a brooch today and I'll see you
next a P Wheels episode oh right at the
fair
let's all a bit